people like shaco mafuro came to
reconcile between us and you rejected it
you rejected the aki
islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are well inshallah
i'm doing this video and i do not
intend on doing any follow-up videos
inshallah because it's totally waste of
my time i'll be honest with you this a
waste of almost time it's unneeded um
and i'm the reason i'm doing this is so
you guys can have a bit of context now
i'm going to sub categorize the people
that are watching this there's going to
be rotten word or enemies of islam
basically they'll be watching this then
you have people that don't like myself
and hijab or whoever it may be and then
you have those who do not are aware who
are not biased they are genuinely aware
of both sides etc and they want to hear
out and the other group is those who
have no idea what's going on they've
just come here you guys can also benefit
but my main video is for this group here
these two i'm not really concerned about
they don't really bother me i'll be
honest with you people that dislike me
or the enemies of islam you're not my
concern
so i want to start the video of very
categorically clearly saying that
about a week ago maybe more than a week
ago i go into a discussion where i had
some objectives with an individual who
was a clerical enemy of islam who has
insulted the prophet for
god knows how long he makes a career
this he earns money out of this you know
at his friend rotten woods same
individuals who insult the prophet
dehumanize muslims and mock the death of
muslims a pilgrimage can you imagine
anywhere but pilgrimage and when they go
in there when they're in this they don't
have
they just go in there to just have a
connection with their lord you know
wearing two pieces of clothes and this
individual actually mocks their death
and these are the people that dehumanize
muslims and our i again say are the main
reason why islam muslims get attacked on
the street my wife walking down the road
on myself being attacked the new zealand
attacker i have no doubt that if the new
zealand attack at christchurch watched
these two individuals videos he would
not say you know what they've changed my
mind against muslims in islam i know i
put my weapons down no instead he would
carry more uh
more armor more bullets to kill more
muslims
so therefore i want to make that very
category clear of who i was dealing with
and it was not a debate so i had a
discussion i put my hands up the way i
conducted myself uh was desperate it was
cringe um it was unneeded but my hate
towards him
uh was so great because of all these
things that i mentioned dehumanizing
muslims
the death of muslims insulting the
prophet for years on end desecrating the
quran
and many many more things so i think
it's justified my anger however as a
muslim i should know better i wrestled
with a pig and i got dirty and i have to
put my hands up to that and i have
however
dealing with the enemy and expecting
blows from the enemy is something we all
expect that's why in the quran
allah is so severe by the munafikun
because they are people who pretend to
be muslims and they
you know they try to you know pretend to
be muslims and they are digging their
grave basically you know in the back now
i want to make it very clear i'm not
calling anyone i'm on africa i'm not
saying nothing none of that but i'm just
giving a context of how severe is now
you expect that from an enemy but you do
not expect that from a person who you
have a private dialogue with who you
talk with who somebody you can discuss
with i have many of these people in my
life people like sheikh with my farooq
muhammadi jab hamza zorse sabor
for read
brother halibe i think his name is the
the other brothers the detective guy i
can't remember all of their names um
many other people who are in my life who
genuinely want the best and the same
goes with me advising them alhamdulillah
all of them got in contact with me uh
not all of them going caught up with me
regarding this discussion but all of
them got in contact with me and you know
they shared their disappointment not
only just in like you know
what happened with this brother sajid
and what he did but also also there also
the nasir and the disappointment in the
way i conducted myself i put my hands up
i'm a human being however what i'm
trying to say here is that
where a lot of people who went on the
other spectrum and joined forces with
the enemy how now i want to make it very
categorically and clear i am open to
advice i am not someone that's
infallible i have never ever said i
cannot be advised i have to be advised
because that's the principle i follow
anytime i've advised other people
youtubers whatever it may be we follow a
protocol which is that if somebody's an
open facet doing evil deeds and
promoting it it's your job to give them
the seer and one lie with even with
these people we try to reach out to them
in private because we don't want the
muslims to seem like we're attacking
each other because the enemies love it
so with an facet somebody who's an open
evildoer according to evil even with
them we advise them in private why
because we want to be sincere if you're
sincere you would say look if i'm an
opportunistic person i would say this
person has done that i'm gonna go in
public why because that shows i have a
disease in my heart i'm looking for
their fault when can i catch them out
this is a disease with brother adam with
brother footy troop with dina tokyo
others we have tried our best to reach
out to them and we've got shunt etcetera
obviously
i'm talking about before
so therefore we have no choice by uh
talking to our uh people of knowledge
our shares our teachers then we are told
you know what you have to do a public
video trying to advise them this is what
we do because if you are sincere you
will not want to look for opportunities
like i don't know which scholar it was i
forgot he said if one advises their
brother in public he's disgraced them
and if he's advised him in private he's
honored them something along those lines
the point i'm trying to make here i'm
not saying necessarily anyone that does
something in public is humiliating them
no no because if he's an open facet
you're bound to now what surprised and
shocked me are two things
i had the discussion friday night
towards midnight
sajid
has my number i've had no problems with
him yes the issue of what he did about
hijab when public was i believe it was
wrong and i convey that you know with
the discussion back and forth et cetera
however just imagine this guys it's as
if
he was waiting for the opportunity
friday night i have that discussion
saturday he films it with another one
called after rahman and he edits it and
the video is out first thing sunday
morning
now i want you guys to put yourself in
my shoes
i am not infallible and i never claim to
be if i do wrong i am bound to be
corrected publicly if i'm a fascist if
i've done something which is haram and
we know eben tammy in his book
has said that when it comes to the
process i'm saying if you see evil stop
it with your hand if not with your hands
stop it with your tongue if not with
your tongue hate it in your heart he
said this is the first one is mainly
generally to the rulers yeah trying to
stop it with your hand yeah the second
one obviously is someone that can you
know speak out against it but even
tamiya may allah says if the harm is
going to be greater then you're not
actually enjoying a good effort and evil
you're causing more harm you're trying
to do something good by causing more
harm as a person of knowledge sajid who
has studied in medina i couldn't believe
the way he rushed about it and edited
and filmed and released it the next day
as if there was no hikmah behind it i
was thinking no problem and with this by
the way there's general public muslims
who are put into the categories not to
these ones who jump on board make fake
accounts not all of them are fake by the
way there'll be a delusion to think that
all of them were fake there were genuine
people who came and said
it was not conducted right and to me
this shows that even though i kind of
maybe wrestling with the pig got messy
the muslim ummah standards are so high
that they call it out and i'm not
talking about what sajid and others done
i do not i see that as an backstabbing i
see but those who genuinely came and
criticized in a positive way yeah i that
shows me how honorable islam has made
muslims that they call out even they
didn't they could have side with me they
could have stabbed me and said no et
cetera no they did say brother ali may
be here that was wrong sincere advice
not hey stop doing dawah et cetera these
are people who are either pretend to be
muslim or have animosity towards us
because who would come and say you know
what you've been doing that for a decade
most of the time you talk about good
good character etc you face the enemy of
islam you dealt in a way which you
should have not maybe it wasn't
befitting for you to do that but then
come and see you stop doing dawah you
should never do that etc does that sound
like someone genuine someone sincere if
somebody does a public video etc does
that sound sincere to me it doesn't it
doesn't people who were sincere which
the names are mentioned about shaffer or
hijab
i had meetings behind the scenes yeah i
had you guys don't know they came and
gave genuineness here because they love
me they love it and i saw that in them
some of their criticism might be a
little bit harsh but i know it's because
of love now which brings me back to this
very issue we thought you know what i
was i was a bit angry upset that sajid
goes and does this it was backstabbing
to me i spoke to some people and i said
you know what
leave this for the sake of allah
if sajid done that video because he
believes i cause damage to islam with
abdul rahman hassan no problem i said
okay let's leave this so i got in
contact with uh
uh
farooq who's done a video on the free
muslim podcast i think and he mentioned
that there should be reconciliation
hijab before that couple of days before
put his hand out with the olive tree and
he said look let's reconcile
we didn't hear nothing from sajid
then
and farooq
we didn't hear nothing from sajid then i
went on twitter and said look i am
willing to reconcile for the sake of
allah for the good of the ummah for the
muslims no problem even though i believe
you backstab i genuinely believe you
backstabbed 100 percent there was no
need for that absolutely because i
didn't do anything that was a sin he
didn't bring any sub i had he didn't
catch me an argument for it to be a
disaster it wasn't like that however the
way i conducted myself i put my hands up
i do this it's been two days and
saturday is quiet
now if your concern sajid was that
i made islam look bad or i didn't
conduct myself or whatever it may be or
it's not your liking whatever it may be
okay
and you believe that was harm now us
arguing within each other me you and
hijab whatever it may be
is
is it beneficial to islam and muslims no
because the enemies are having a party
and to be honest i don't really care you
know at the end of the day islam is
regardless of what happens and what we
do you get it there's hundreds and
thousands of people coming to islam so
to me i know alhamdulillah islam is the
truth and they've got nothing else to do
because they're realizing that their
religion and what they're on is
falsehood and it's not working and all
they do is attack
so to me
i i don't see it as a loss in that sense
i'm a nobody let me let me be humiliated
as long as islam rises and exactly
that's what happened because even though
i made myself look cringe and
embarrassing at certain moments yeah
even though i had certain objectives
which i are fulfilled hamdulillah even
though i did that this showed that
muslims handle how honorable they are
that they take us to account they
clearly decide was for the sake of it
that shows how subhan allah
truthful they are and i'm not talking
about what sag had done so
i called i i went to shaykh with my
pharaoh and
look we said we want to reconcile now if
that's the case sajid if your concern is
how muslim is how islam is seen
why have you rejected a reconciliation
now this puts into account your
intentions to me
because if your intentions were in the
right place number one you would never
rush to do a video on such a matter that
wasn't extreme you didn't see me go
there as far as mom insult his dad uh
swear his eyes children his kids and do
some chaos like i don't know i took my
shirt off and i started ripping it and i
started hitting myself i didn't do
anything to that extreme he actually was
insulting me and swearing at me and you
know yes i had some grapes and i acted a
bit you know funny for the sake of just
to get under his skin which i did
hamdullah and and i'm proud of that so
the thing is other than that yes there's
things that are done wrong there was
nothing
a personal knowledge like you should
know that needed to be called out
so now why are you not coming to the
reconciliation table why are you not
coming sajid
this is my point here brothers and
sisters just because someone speaks on a
specific tone and he's calm and he's you
know his demeanor is you know in a
certain way
it doesn't mean anything because if
sajid genuinely wanted the good for the
muslims he would have come and reconcile
he doesn't want to
and i heard from different sources that
he is even angry and upset at the
thought of it
so now let's put this to question
and now to me it shows categorically and
clear that sajid has a personal issue
which i do not know what it is i've had
no problem
with him we had our differences very
minou nothing big
but one thing that i saw him saw with
him is this dogmatic approach when it
came to this youtube ads things yeah and
i'm not gonna be petty and et cetera
show um the the comments because i spoke
to the shorter group i spoke to some
brothers they said it's petty don't be
don't be petty no problem
if it's because he said you know if i
show these and it'll be really
detrimental to me no it's not because i
mentioned to you very categorically and
clearly the reasons and the people that
i spoke with and he was like no you
can't but now youtube they put youtube
ads and you are willing to carry on
doing your videos to me is hypocrisy i'm
not even going to talk about that now
let's read i want to read to you guys
guys i want to read to you guys
abdul rahman sajid who invited him by
the way abraham was talking to him he
didn't seem like a sincere guy who i
believe um was just you know i don't
know if sajid invited him whatever
happened but he
came to us and about reconciliation etc
he opened up to us i saw sincerity in
that however still sajid allowed him to
do most of the talking um which is as
good as sajid doing the talking yeah
this is what he said and this is where i
totally disagree look at the attitude
towards believers compared to
disbelievers okay enemies of islam i've
just have just finished watching the
debate between ali dawa and apostate
prophet i left the following comment
addressed to ali and i'm reporting it
here just in case it's censored
from beginning to end you utterly
humiliated yourself and tried to drag
islam down with you
why would i try to drag islam down with
me
and how did i communicate myself by okay
there was things that was you know like
hijabs is overcooked etc no problem
was it that bad yeah did you did i
insult his mom his dad and what are you
talking about let's go with it
you behave like a you behave like a
petulant
petroleum
in basilic
invested a child and bought no single
good argument ap undermined you on on
each and every point the best thing for
you and your team to do it
for your team to do for encouraging
mockery of islam the way you did would
be to make a toba and distance yourself
from this video
listen carefully this is actually
backbite yeah it's calling me names yeah
an imbecile yeah a child yeah all these
kind of names yeah now look at this guys
this is our problem me and hijab and
when we do about videos about the s pubs
etc this is exactly our point now look
at his letter
he's writing to david wood and ap apus
dr david wood
on your podcast last night in reviewing
my review of the apv's the debate you
said
that's on the screen for you guys i'm
not going to read the whole thing this
long yeah
look at his tone
and i'm not just saying this is same
with sagittarius because
they did the video together they are
both to blame
look at their approach towards the
enemies of islam who desecrate the quran
who eat the quran who chew it who mock
the death of the believers
who do we've been doing videos for years
on end insulting the prophet
dr david wood and apos apostate prophet
won't even call me apostate prophet
that to me is shocking
guys i cannot believe
that you can call me names back by me
call me names and when it comes to
david wood it's doctor david wood and
somebody asked a question he said why
don't you call hijab ustad hijab i'll
give him something not that we need him
but why don't you give him that respect
why don't you when it comes to me why
don't you call me like brother aki or in
the tone you know why this is our
problem to me
it is social because allah says in the
quran
and
prophet uh and muhammad sallallahu
alaihi means his final messenger and
those who believe
are harsh towards the disbelievers and
go towards believers yeah something like
this or vice versa okay
and even kafir when he says he says
those who believe that because the ayah
starts with what believes muhammad's
final messenger the characteristics that
they have because those who testify that
the prophet saws find a messenger have
to be soft towards the believers and
harsh towards the enemies of islam these
believers
we see the absolute opposite
the absolute opposite
for them to attack us and this is the
reason why we've done a whole
there's a channel called sp files where
we dismantle individuals like s-pops who
do nothing but attack the muslims and
sajid to me it's very disingenuous wow
mentions and uses this to show hypocrisy
that oh you talk about not attacking
muslims but you are the same guys who
have sp files who attack muslims it's
like me seeing a bully who's a muslim
slapping muslims abusing them and then i
go and start stopping him and abusing
him and somebody comes in and then i
have a go at someone saying you know
these guys are attacking muslims and
they go well you've done the same thing
how disingenuous you must be to use that
as an example where you yourself have
been attacked by sp s
and you have also
called them out
and now you're using that to be the same
thing where we are out there tackling
individuals who ban people from the
mosques of allah literally ban people
from mosques they slap beat up muslims
physically physically
they they are always taking the sight of
the enemies
and they continuously attack muslims and
slander scholars and backed by muslims
on a mass scale and that is the same as
us calling them out and saying stop
doing this and stop oppressing the
believers
and that that means we're hypocrites
because you know um you we say oh you do
that and then you say oh but you guys do
it as well you that's disingenuous to me
in a nutshell guys i've read it for you
guys
and
sajid you are falling sajan abdul rahman
you guys are that gullible that you are
falling for this let me read one comment
i'm going to end on this now yeah
this was a message sargent read in his
video
where he's trying to say there are there
are people that genuine non-muslims are
also agreeing with him we're gonna go to
this guy's channel his name is samyo
onoko yeah i like how you sound
respectful i don't believe in islam uh
islam but for real this is the best i've
seen on the youtube of muslims he's
talking about this video that i did
attacking me which i believe is
backstabbing yeah
you only take away from it you only take
away from the debate was that islam will
be wiped out no the only take away from
the debate was that islam will be wiped
out anyways you guys have a lot to do in
this sincere spirit and it has to be
really fast maybe good luck
and sergeant is that gullible that
gullible that he reads this and says
look you know i've got sincere people
let's look at who's this channel this
guy's is and look look what i found guys
this way who is he following yeah he
sounds like a sincere non-muslim guy you
know like abdul rahman after man said
you know since non-muslims were watching
this are you guys that gullible and
naive that they have got us attacking
each other which well you guys attacked
us first and we're here trying to defend
ourselves who is he following dcci
ministries does that ring a bell are
this uh is this not the same group that
comes to the uh
to the par and drills the quran drill
drill rip rip rip insult the prophet
have pictures of the prophet um who else
do they follow let's look oh david wood
very sincere non-muslim who else do they
follow
acts 17 apologetics apostate prophet who
else do they follow christian prince
islam critiqued um and the list goes on
and you are that gullible that you think
these people are coming and they're
telling you encouraging you carry on you
know people like us do you not think
it's because they see me and mohammed
jab and the others are the biggest
threat and they are doing this so we can
fight each other
and sajis are you that gullible lucky
are you that gullible lucky that you are
thinking these people are genuine people
yeah
you've said you fell right into their
trap and we called you for
reconciliation you know what that means
you have a personal issue with us and i
see your video as insincere the fact
that you waited to release it that quick
i totally rejected this year you know
why because it was nothing but
backstabbing it was opportunistic and it
was backstabbing to me alhamdulillah
people like sheikh mafuro came to
reconcile between us and you rejected it
you rejected the aki that shows me that
this was never about for the sake of
allah from day one and the points that
you brought about me i'm the reason why
a person saws a prophet
really
really
somebody who's been insulting the
prophet from day one and all of a sudden
when i came here insulted that miss my
fault so let's use an argument from the
quran and sunnah so
nicknamed them that
so this is a very very very similar
nearly identical
this name i didn't give april that name
by the way it's given by someone else no
problem the process
yeah so does that mean now to your logic
that the prophet sallam is wrong because
he named him that and he and he ended up
insulting the prophet and islam et
cetera
there's your evidence tell me why it's
not the case
me acting arrogant in a certain way it's
not going oh obviously i went a bit
about okay abu dhojana yeah in the
battle of
when he was walking proudly in the
companion sorry and said look why is he
doing that they were they were
criticizing him just as the way you guys
were criticizing me yeah and yes i went
a bit overboard and they went to the
prophet and the prophet said said this
action i was walking proudly and
arrogantly yeah is hated by allah except
in this situation and that's gonna say
some people people of you know when
you're facing the enemy
for the sake of allah in that situation
you can't act in an arrogant way
in in certain context
that is the evidence
and lastly i'll finish on this guys that
you defended apus
i couldn't believe my ears when i said
he's the reason why innocent muslims are
being attacked on the streets you
actually rebuked me and saying how
basically in a nutshell how dare i
misconstrue that how dare i somebody who
insults the prophet day in day night day
in day out you defend his honor
tommy robinson has he ever come out and
called for the killing of muslims never
never
but here's the reason why many people
who have carried out attacks even he had
connections to the christchurch attacker
by another means yeah
yeah this person
in his manifesto the guy who ran over
people in frisbee park
he quoted tommy robinson now has tommy
robinson ever made videos no he hasn't
are we that gullible how is that silly
that you are defending apus and accusing
me of blaming him apparently ali
unjustly blamed apus for the attack on
muslims how dare you
and look at the tone you take with him
and look at the tone you take with me
look at the defense you give him and
look at the attack you give me
that's all i'm going to say and this is
the reason why people individuals like
you who are dogmatic
who think that we have to follow your
way and
if we don't you attack us i've dealt
with people like you before sadly and
i'm not going to waste my time i'm just
doing this video to show gullible you
are and not only that we have called you
out to reconciliation and you have
rejected it let the entire muslim world
know that you are not here this specific
thing for the sake of allah don't come
to mistake of allah if you genuinely
care about islam's image i was fighting
and we're telling you let's reconcile me
jabba saying come let's reconcile well
but brothers it's not that deep and you
reject it and i've heard from other
sources that you're even angry at the
fact of that
shame on you
that's all i have to say brother sisters
inshallah i'm not perfect i have to be
reprimanded and
put to account if i do something that
crossed my line against islam whatever
it may be yes but this was opportunistic
backstabbing which i believe
and we wanted to reconcile he didn't
that's on him until next time assalamu
alaikum
i'll be dealing with more important
stuff love and sisters i've got time for
this inshallah
take care and inshallah may allah bless
you guys and keep us firm inshaallah and
allow us to learn from our mistakes